[Music]
these colorful fabrics are made in
mali jellica kone runs this business in
the capital bamako
today she has about 100 employees mostly
women but also their families
if her enterprise is now thriving it's
in part thanks to a loan from a local
microfinancing scheme
backed by the european investment bank
the eu's lending arm
this allowed jellica to invest in and
grow her business
[Music]
odb is attacking
global europe is the eu's new
development and international
cooperation program
funding will be dispersed to
organizations such as local and
international ngos
associations and agencies like in mali
it will support sustainable growth in eu
neighborhood countries
as well as further afield it will merge
several existing eu funding instruments
and reinforce
key european priorities such as
empowering women like angelica
important global europe will support
projects that promote eu values such as
human rights and democracy
or address global challenges like the
climate crisis and migration
over the coming seven years it will
invest more than 79 billion euros in
infrastructure projects education
healthcare
small businesses and much more ensuring
the eu remains the world's single
biggest investor
in development parliament will have a
say in the implementation of the new
global europe program
we have to follow our
historical leadership on on development
and by assisting our partners we
are contributing ourselves for european
stability security prosperity the eu
will continue to work with
international regional and local
partners to ensure it lives up to its
commitments around the world
you